السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته الله الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اشهد ان
لا اله الا الله
اشهد
ان
اله الا الله
اشهد ان
محمدا رسول
الله اشهد
ان
محم
رسول الله
حي على الصلاه
[Silence]
حي على
الصلاه حي على
[Silence]
الفلا حي الفلا
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا الا
[Silence]
الله ان الحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه
ونستهديه ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن
سيئات اعمالنا من يهدي الله فهو المهتد
ومن يضلل فلا هادي له واشهد ان لا ال اله
الا الله وحده لا شريك له واشهد ان محمدا
عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه والتابعين اما بعد
معاشر الموحدين عباد الله فان اصدق الكلام
كلام الله عز وجل وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى
الله عليه وسلم وان شر الامور محدثاتها
وان كل محدثه بدعه وان كل بدعه ضلاله وان
كل له في النار اسال الله العظيم رب العرش
العظيم بمنه وكرمه وعفوه ان يجيرني واياكم
منها انه ولي ذلك والقادر
عليه اما بعد فيقول الله سبحانه وتعالى يا
ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي خلقكم من نفس
واحده وخلق منها زوجها وبث منهما رجالا
كثيرا
ونساء واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به
والارحام ان الله كان عليكم رقيبا ويقول
سبحانه وتعالى يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا
الله حق تقاته ولا تموتن الا وانتم
مسلمون ويقول سبحانه وتعالى يا ايها الذين
امنوا اتقوا الله وقولوا قولا سديدا يصلح
لكم اعمالكم ويغفر لكم
ذنوبكم ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا
عظيما اما
بعد لا شك بان المشاهد القاسيه التي تاتي
ابتداء من
غزه ولبنان وسوريا والسودان هي مشاهد
قاسيه والقائمه
تطول لكنها اصبحت
مالوفه والمسلم اليوم على قساوه هذه
المشاهد فليس له ان يعجب من كثره القتل
والتشريد والهرج والتجويع والخوف والفساد
والظواهر السيئه والعادات
الدخيله لا عجب من هذا
كله لان المتامل
للتاريخ المتامل والقارئ للتاريخ
وتحديدا تاريخ النزيف الدموي للمسلمين ول
الام يعلم ان هذا كله مما عاشه الناس
ويعيشون الان وسيعيش في
المستقبل اي ان كل ما يحدث فقد كان مثله
بالامس ويكون اليوم وسيكون غدا وهذا كله
من سنن الله سبحانه وتعالى في الخلق
وابتلاءات واصطفاء
ته وكما ذكرنا هذا ليس
بالعج ولكن ا اتدرون ما العجيب وما اعجب
من
كله اعجب ما يكون هو الوقت في هذا الزمان
تسارع الوقت وتقارب
الزمان اعجب ما يكون هو سرعه الوقت وكيف
تمضي الايام
[Silence]
‏all
h
going new not to us
should even difficult
difficult and was
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
‏all
time
speed speed
time days
ولعل اكثر ما
تذكر بها به سرعه الايام هو دنوب الاخره
والساعه بلا شك لان سرعتها او انعدام
البركه منها هو من علامات الساعه التي بلغ
عنها النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم كما جاء في
حديث النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم عن انس بن
مالك رضي الله عنه انه قال قال رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم لا تقوم الساعه حتى
يتقارب
الزمان حتى يتقارب الزمان فتكون السنه
كالشهر والشهر كالجمع وتكون الجمعه كاليوم
ويكون اليوم كالساعه وتكون الساعه
كالضرع النار وانطفاء في نبته او شيء سريع
اسرع ما يكون
‏so you are feeling
[Silence]
time يوم القيامه
البركه وانعدامها من
الوقت
بركه صلى الله عليه وسلم انس صلى الله
عليه وسلم
ان
[Silence]
يوم القيامه
ساعه ويقول المفسرون في هذا الحديث
المبارك ان السرعه هي اما سرعه فعليه في
الوقت او انعدام البركه فيشعر الانسان لو
كان يومه اصبح كساعه او اسبوعه كيوم وهذا
ملموس ولا يغيب عن احساس حضراتكم كيف
السرعه التي يعقب بها الليل والنهار يتبع
النهار الليل والمسلم لا ينبغي ان يهتم في
الحقيقه لسرعه الايام ولا لوقتها ولا
لسرعه انقضائها اذا كان كله
لله المسلم اليوم لا يهتم ولا يتاثر لسرعه
انقضاء الوقت او انعدام البركه اذا كان كل
ما يفنى من عمره وايامه في طاعه الله لا
ينبغي للمسلم ان يتاثر لامر الوقت اذا كان
باني لاخرته غير ناسيا لامر دنياه وهذا
مما وصى به سبحانه وتعالى في محكم كتابه
وابتغ فيما اتاك الله الدار
الاخره ولا تنسى نصيبك من الدنيا واحسن
كما احسن الله اليك ولا تبغي الفساد في
الارض ان الله لا يحب
المفسدين الهدف الرئيسي والحقيقي هو تسخير
ما اتاك الله من وقت ومال وصحه وجاه في
ابتغاء الاخره لكن لا تنسى نصيبك من
الدنيا في التمتع بالحلال والاستكثار من
الخير وانفاق وانفاقه فيما ينفع
اخرتك ايه
حديث ذا كتب
تفسير
ب صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏either
speed
time could of bl and
time wake up in
the رمضان
ران ان شاء الله another ran very
quick should
‏time
speed
life الله سبحانه
وتالى
was why
care الله سبحانه
وتالى does not
care aff speed ‏passing of the
time because we said if your entire life
to allah سانه wala then kind makes makes
no difference if your day going by very
quick or very slow in either case the
entire life subhan wa taala but do not
forget about your
dunia and this is the
aah we just read الله سبحانه
وتالى home of the and do not neg your of
this so brothers not
the
not not
for come of the
day and
‏not الدنيا وابتغ فيما اتاك الله الدار
الاخره ولا تنسى نصيبك من
الدنيا الله سبحانه
وتالى
الله corruption
earthed الله does notr
‏heal money children seeking
the and do
not
notre all given
اخ عجيب امر
الدنيا عجيب امر الدنيا كما يقول المتاخر
تفت فؤادك الايام فتا وتنحت جسمك الساعات
نحتا وتدعوك المنون دعاء صدق الا يا صاحي
انت اريد
انت اخي المسلم المحروم اليوم من حرم
الادراك واليقظه من الغفله هذا متعلق بولد
وهذا متعلق بوظيفه وهذا متعلق
بتجاره حتى تكاد احاديثنا تكون دنيويه
بحته لا تكاد ترتفع قباب البيوت
والمساجد حدثني عن الاخره والسعي لها
حدثني عن الله والجنه والنار حدثني عن
الكوثر حدثني عن الصراط المستقيم حدثني عن
يوم الحساب فريق في الجنه وفريق في السعير
سبحان وتالى and the last day and this is
when time makes no difference in your
life you wouldn't care
time
att mind life att الله
سانى not
[Silence]
‏fin
يقول يا ليتني قدمت لحياتي حياته التي
يتكلم عنها هي الاخره بعد ما ترك كل شيء
خلف
ظهره اين الملوك ومن بالارض قد عمروا قد
فارقوا ما بن بنوا فيها وعمروا اين
العساكر ما ردت وما نفعت واين ما جمعت
جمعوا فيها وما ادخروا بارك الله لي ولكم
بالقران العظيم ونفعني واياكم بهدي سيد
المرسلين اقول ما تسمعون واستغفر الله لي
ولكم فاستغفروه انه الغفور
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين والصلاه
والسلام على المبعوث رحمه
للعالمين اللهم صل و سلم وبارك على سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اللهم وارضى
عنا وعنهم
اجمعين ومما لا شك فيه ان المسلم كما قلنا
ايامه وانفاسه واعماله كلها لله سبحانه
وتعالى يقول الله سبحانه وتعالى قل ان
صلاتي ونسكي ومحياي ومماتي لله رب
العالمين وان هذه
الحياه وان الحياه في هذه الدنيا سريعه
وكذلك التصرف فيها والعمل يجب يكون بناء
على هذا الفهم قوله صلى الله عليه وسلم
لابن عمر كن في الدنيا كانك غريب كن في
الدنيا كانك غريب او عابر سبيل يعني لا
تركن اليها لا تركن اليها فالغريب ياخذ
حاجته فقط ويمشي
الله سبحانه وتالى الله سبحانه وتعالى
قران my
life الله سبحانه
وتالى life
inck
passing
soing
you qui
‏building for the
per permanent state after
this صل الله عليه
وسلمن صلى عليه
وسلم as
‏both they come quickly quickly they
take to
much صلى الله عليه
وسلم all us like
اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد في الاولين
وصل وسلم على سيدنا محمد في الاخرين وصل
وسلم على سيدنا محمد في كل وقت وحين اللهم
صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد حتى ترث الارض ومن
عليها وانت خير
الوارثين اللهم اعز الاسلام والمسلمين
واعلي رايتي الحق والدين المبين اللهم
ابرم لنا ولهذه الامه امرا رشدا ي تع تعز
فيه وليك وتذل فيه عدوك ويعمل فيه بطاعتك
اللهم ككل لاخواننا المستضعفين في كل مكان
اللهم اصلح احوالنا واحوال المسلمين في كل
مكان اللهم انت احصيت عددا اللهم انت
احصيت عددا وحالا وموقعا فكن معهم رب يا
رب العالمين اي اينما كانوا اللهم احفظنا
واحفظهم بما تحفظ به اوليائك اللهم احفظهم
واحفظنا بما تحفظ اوليائك اللهم اسقنا
الغيث ولا تجعلنا من القانطين اللهم اسقنا
غيثا مغيثا مريئا نافعا غير ضار اللهم
اسقنا
غيثا مغيثا مريئا نافعا غير ضار اللهم انت
الله لا اله الا انت انت الغني ونحن
الفقراء انزل علينا الغيث ولا تجعلنا من
القانطين اللهم اجعل هذا المجتمع امنا
سخاء رخاء وسائر بلاد المسلمين اللهم
تجاوز عنا السيئات وتحمل عنا
التبعات اللهم اجزي والدينا عنا خير
الجزاء اللهم اجز والدينا عنا خير الجزاء
اللهم من كان منهم حيا فاطل في عمره وبارك
له في عمره وعمله واختم لنا ولهم بخاتمه
الاحسان ومن توفيته منهم يا رب العالمين
فاكرهم واغفر لهم وارحمهم انك ولي ذلك
والقادر عليه اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه والتابعين اللهم احينا
على سنه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم وامتنا
على ملته واوردنا حوضه واكتب لنا شفاعته
يا رب العالمين عباد الله ان الله يامر
بالعدل والاحسان وايتاء ذي القربى وينهى
عن الفحشاء والمنكر والبغي
يعظكم لعلكم تذكرون واخر دعوانا ان الحمد
لله رب العالمين واقيم
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا الله اشهد
ان لا اله الا الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الصلاه حي على الفلاح حي
على
الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله استقيم
استوا سصف سد
الخلل الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك ك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين سبح اسم ربك الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى
والذي قدر فهدى الذي اخرج
المرعى فجعله
غثاء
احوى سنقرئك فلا
تنسى الا ما
شاء
الله
انه يعلم الجهر وما
يخفى ونيسرك
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت الذكرى
سيذكر
من يخشى
ويتجنبها
الاتقى الذي يصل
الاشقى الذي يصلى النار
الكبرى
ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من تزكى وذكر اسم ربه
فصلى بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا
والاخره خير
وابقى
ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف
ابراهيم وموسى
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستق
مستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين هل اتاك حديث الغاشيه وجوه يومئذ
خاشعه
عامله ناصبه
تصلى نارا حاميه تسقى من عين انيه ليس لهم
طعام الا من
ضريع لا يسمن ولا يغني من جوع وجوه
يومئذ ناعمه لسعيها
راضيه في
جنه عاليه
لا تسمع فيها
لاغيه فيها عين جاريه فيها سرر
مرفوعه
واكواب
موضوعه
ونمارق
مصفوفه
وزرابي
مبثوثه افلا
ينظرون الى الابل كيف خلقت والى السماء
كيف رفعت والى الجبال كيف نصبت والى
الارض والى الارض كيف سطحت فذكر
انما انت
مذكر لست عليهم بمسيطر
الا من تولى وكفر
فيعذبه الله العذاب
الاكبر
ان
الينا
ايابهم
ثم ان علينا
حسابهم الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الس
‏people
[Silence]
‏so work are do so
sister some that would ask don first
[Silence]
ا
‏at just encourage because guys are the
work are resp for 000 anybody hand for
that that's
only 100
mon
any just ask for 1000
‏sister
any tak care
so 500
[Silence]
donly again
‏foc mann in so and sister pleas ask to
be there jo us and us now there are
other things that we have to
rem at the of the year we ask for
the the donation your ta dos the state
of
ta academy and thats a
[Silence]
لام ه